[Musique]
et notre invité ce matin c'est Robert
Ménard bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous depuis votre mairie de béziier
Mare divers droite de bisier Robert
Ménard merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation on va parler évidemment de
cette marche de ces marches contre
l'antisémitisme qui avait lieu hier à
travers tout le pays vous étiez vous euh
dans la marche à Paris qu'avez-vous
ressenti d'abord du soulagement pour
tout vous dire parce qu'il y avait
beaucoup de monde et on était tous à se
dire est-ce que les les Français vont
répondre est-ce que on va pouvoir aller
au-delà de de la seule communauté juive
est-ce que les Français qui ne sont pas
juifs vont montré leur solidarité et
donc il y avait un vrai soulagement
ensuite il y avait un sentiment fait
comme quand on se retrouve en famille si
je dire qu'on a chaud au cœur et qu'on
se dit tiens on est tous là et ça fait
du bien je crois qu'il qu'il y avait
qu'il avait ce sentiment et puis il y
avait une autre un autre plaisir si
j'ose dire même si c'était grave c'était
de se dire que malgré toutes les
polémique politicienne vous savez j'y
vais j'y vais pas j'y vais pas avec
celui-là j'y vais avec celui-là tout ça
on l'avait oublié on se trouvit entre
citoyens entre citoyens loin des partis
politiques loin des partis politiques à
se dire il y a des choses qui sont plus
fortes que la politique il y a des
valeurs qui sont plus importantes que le
jeu politique des uns et des autres donc
voilà c'était c'était un beau moment moi
je l'ai vécu comme comme un beau moment
et j'étais content d'être là est-ce que
est-ce que ces marches vous les avez
ressentis comme un un motif d'espérance
c'est ce qu'a dit Emmanuel
Macron écoutez un motif d'espérance sur
le coup oui reste que je ne suis pas sûr
que que ça règle les problèmes de fond
vous savez on a tous envie de de
participer à un moment comme ça mais une
une fois passé le moment on se dit
qu'est-ce qui va se passer par exemple
aujourd'hui demain ou après-demain euh
pardon c'est je sais bien que on nous
explique qu'on parle pas d'Israël qu'on
parlait que de l'antisémitisme en France
mais la situation au Moyen Orient elle
est la toile de fond de cette montée de
de
l'antisémitisme en France et sur le
conflit lui-même moi j'étais la semaine
dernière à à nirose vous savez ce ce
kibuts qui est juste à côté de de de
Gaza qui où il y a eu tant de massacres
et de disparition là la situation elle
va pas changer aujourd'hui ce qui se
passe en Israël l'obligation pour Israël
de de se défendre ça ça va pas changer
donc il va y avoir encore des images de
de de Gaza sous les bombes et tout
est-ce que ça ça va pas alimenter une
nouvelle fois un antisémitisme je je le
crains voilà c'est ça veut dire que je
pense ça et puis pardon il y a encore
une fois il y a tout un tas de gens qui
utilise ça pour des raisons politiques
et ils vont pas arrêter demain le faire
qui qui par exemple utilise ça pour des
raisons
politiques par exemple la France
insoumise mais enfin je veux dire ça s
au quand même ce qui m'a d'abord frappé
c'est c'est l'absence de la France
insoumise la France insoumise qui qui
comment dire qui surf sur ce qu'elle
pensa être un
antisémitisme ou une haine d'Israël
omniprésente dans un certain nombre de
quartiers où elle fait ses plus forts
scores électoraux c'est aussi minable
que ça je dis pas tous les élus de la
France àist dieu merci il y en a un
certain nombre qui se sont qui se sont
détachés en tout cas qui ont qui ont
émis un certain nombre de critiqu sur
Jean-Luc Mélanchon mais bien sûr qu'on
assiste à ça et ça c'est un minable
absolu enfin attendez pour des calculs
électorals pour flatter pour gagner
quelqu quelques voix vous êtes prêt à la
fois à refuser de dire que le Hamas est
une organisation terroriste et à ne pas
être présent quand toutes les Chiquet
politiques parce qu'il y avait pas que
la droite et l'extrême droite comme le
dit Mélenchon hier dans la rue mais il y
avait aussi les autres partis de gauche
ils étaient là moi je les ai VO on les
voyait dire ça veut dire que pour vous
la France insoumise qui a justifié son
absence par la présence du rassemblement
national c'était un prétexte mais bien
sûr que c'est un prétexte ils flattent
leur électorat mais enfin attendez je
sais plus sur quel ton il faut le dire
ils se disent c'est c'est les endroits
où on fait le plus de voix mais c'est
les endroits aussi où il y a le moins de
votant on le sait on a des statistiques
il y a des chiffres sur le peu de
votants dans un certain nombre de
quartiers comme on dit et ils vont
chercher ces voixlà au prix de reniment
je me souviens de d'un Jean-Luc
Mélanchon qui a 20 ans était arquebouté
sur sur sur la laïcité et sur la défense
de la laïcité aujourd'hui tous ces
arguments c'est à l'encontre de ça c'est
ça la réalité et la
présence pardon comment vous l'expliquez
du coup ce revirement de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon mais je pense qu'il y a une
dérive de Jean-Luc Mélanchon il y a un
effondrement de son attachement à ce
pays il y a il y a je sais pas que
comment dire j'ai honte pour lui
honnêtement j'ai honte pour lui et même
vous savez on a beaucoup parlé du du
rassemblement national et de alors
est-ce qu'il fallait qu'il soit là ou
pas les tolérer ou pas d'abord drôle de
question comme si hier ils font de vous
avez demandé pour qui vous votiez ou la
carte de votre parti moi j'en ai aucune
donc c'est pas moi c'est c'est c'est pas
mon problème mais en fait attendez
qu'est-ce que c'est ces calculs le
rassemblement national quand même il y a
il y a des éléments dans la droite qui
sont antisémites ça fait pas l'ombre
d'un doute d'abord Marine Le Pen elle
est pas antisémite puis Marine Le Pen
elle a quand même fait quelque chose
elle a rompu avec son père sur la
question de l'antisémitisme elle l'a mis
dehors du parti qu'il avait créé moi
j'attends de tous les discident ou je
sais pas comment il faut les appeler du
du du de la de la France insoumise
qu'ils ont qu'à Jean-Luc Mélanchon là
ils nous montreront qu'ils sont
conséquents Marine Le Pen elle a rompu
avec son père mais Jordan Bardella pas
plus tard que la semaine dernière a dit
ne pas croire que Jean-Marie Le Pen
était antisémite est-ce que c'était une
faute est-ce que vous comprenez que du
coup leur présence hier interroge avec
ses propos mais c'est une faute et une
imbécilité une idiotie bien sûr que
Jean-Marie Le Pen il est antisémite
enfin on pas ici rappeler tous les
propos sur le détail du Rafour
crématoire et tout je sais pas ce qui a
traversé l'esprit de Jordan Bardella à
ce moment-là enfin comment on peut dire
une inepsie pareil alors on le regrette
on dit que c'est plus le cas enfin on
dit des mots mais on dit pas non il est
pas antisémite mais c'est de laabéce
c'est c'est la preuve qu'il a encore des
choses à rompre mais après manifestement
il a compris qu'il avait dit une
connerie mais c'est vrai qu'elle est le
signe de quelque chose mais attendez moi
je vous dis pas qu'il y a pas de
problème au rassemblement national je
dis qu'on devrait tout moi j'y suis pas
et j'ai jamais été au rassemblé
nationale donc j'ai aucun problème pour
ça mais je n'aurais jamais voté
Jean-Marie Le P alors que j'ai voté
Marine Le Pen parce qu'il y a une
rupture parce qu'elle change au lieu de
s'en féliciter au lieu de s'en féliciter
chacun va chercher des poudes dans la
tête de l'autre moi si demain Jean-Luc
Mélenchon disait publiquement que ce
qu'il a dit sur sur la présidente du de
l'Assemblée nationale vous savez où elle
disait qu'elle campe qu'elle campe à
Jérusalem enfin vous voyez camper à quoi
ça renvoie voilà évidemment que ça ça
flirte avec l'antisémitisme et tout ça
si Jean-Luc Mélenchon disait demain ah
non j'aurais pas dû dire ça je me je me
suis laissé emporter je me trompe mais
j'applaudirai madame moi j'applaudis
dans le chaque fois que quelqu'un va
dans le bon sens et le bon sens c'est la
lutte contre l'antisémitisme et c'est au
aujourd'hui ne pas mettre sur le même
plan le Hamas c'est l'État d'Israël moi
je su pour le RN est-ce que est-ce que
le RN aujourd'hui a vraiment tourné la
page de
l'antisémitisme enfin vous croyez que
Marine Le Pen elle est antisémite enfin
attendez vous pouvez moi je lui reproche
plein de choses je pense que sur le
terrain économique et social elle dit
des conneries euh c'est elle a des
propositions qui sont souvent un peu
démago d'ailleurs qui ressemblent
souvent à la France à soumise sur sur
ces terrainlà mais je vais pas lui faire
lu reproche elle est pas homophobe elle
est pas elle est pas antisémite elle est
pas racistes qui a eu des homophobes des
antisémites et des racistes au
rassemblement national et au Front
national évidemment qui en est encore
oui évidemment mais voilà une fois que
vous avez dit ça Marine Le Pen elle fait
la chasse à ça on peut au moins au moins
lui cononnaître ça on n'est pas obligé
chaque fois parce que on a détesté son
père ou parce qu'on a pensé que son père
on a pas pensé on a constaté que son
père était antisémite ne pas lui faire
enfin de pas avoir la bonne foi de dire
qu'elle a rompu avec ça elle romt avec
ça et sa présence je trouve que c'était
une bonne chose pas une bonne chose pour
eux moi je m'en fous de la
dédiabolisation du du du rassemblement
national ce qui m'intéresse c'est
qu'elle était là et que plus il y a de
gens là et si et si la France est
soumise romper avec un certain nombre de
choses et se trouver dans ces
rassemblements national dans ces
rassemblements là j'applaudirai madame
j'applaudirai vous nous parliez tout à
l'heure du calcul électoral de la France
insoumise pour vous il y avait aucun
calcul électoral dans la présence de
marine lepaniia mais il y en a peut-être
j'ai jamais dit ça moi je sculte pas les
reins et les cœurs des gens je constate
qu'elle était là et qu'il fallait qu'on
y soit tous tant mieux elle était là moi
j'aurais aimé vous croyez qu'il y a pas
du calcul électoral sur les partis de
gauche et bien sûr il y en a mais je
m'en fiche ils étaient là ils étaient là
le par par communiste le Parti
socialiste ils étaient là soit dit en
passant quand Monsieur Mélenchon dit
c'était le rassemblement de la droite et
l'extrême droite bravo pour ses copains
de laanupes voilà c'est c'est la bonne
nouvelle c'est ça la bonne nouvelle
c'est quand les partis Dieu sait que
j'ai des acccords avec eux mais hier le
problème c'était pas les désaccords le
problème c'était nos accords est-ce
qu'il est acceptable est-ce qu'il est
acceptable queil y ait une montée de
l'antisémitisme comme ça non est-ce
qu'il faut se battre pour la libération
des otages oui au moins on se retrouve
là-dessus au moins on se retrouve
là-dessus dessus et hier je vous
garantis moi j'ai discuté avec plein de
gens qui me reconnaissent et qui
viennent me voir et les gens ils me
parlaient pas de nos idées politiques
ils étaient juste contents c'était
chaleureux on avait besoin de se
retrouver ensemble quand il y a une
montée d' césitisme pareil et quand il
se passe ce qui se passe à Gaza et à
Gaza et en l'occurrence en Israël aussi
bien sûr Emmanuel Macron lui n'était pas
présent hier à cette marche contre
l'antisémitisme il a commis une erreur
selon vous
oui bien sûr bien sûr qu'il a commis une
erreur bien sûr qu'il a commis une
erreur sa place était là qu'est-ce qu'il
a dit il a dit attendez j'avais j'avais
noté des choses sur ce qu'il dit il dit
il faut l'unité des Français il faut un
message d'humanité et c'était quoi hier
c'était quoi hier c'était pas un message
d'unité c'était pas un message
d'humanité bien sûr que sa place elle
était là mais je pense qu'il a commis
une erreur peut-être qu'il est il est
mal conseillé peut-être j'espère que
c'est pas un certain nombre de gens qui
lui ont dit oui vous app on pensait
qu'il y aurait moins de gens que ça que
qu'il y a un certain nombre de de gens
autour de lui qui disent ah oui mais
enfin attendez si vous êtes là et qu'il
y a pas trop de monde c'est pas bien
pour votre image non il aurait dû être
là il aurait dû être là il faut qu'il
fasse attention Emmanuel Macron et moi
je suis pas un antimacroniste
systématique évidemment pas mais même là
il aurait dû être là comme il devrait
faire attention à ce qu'il dit vous avez
vu un jour il exige un jour il y a 2
jours il parle qu'il faut à la BBC qu'il
faut arrêter les bombardements et 2
jours après il dit oui ah non mais moi
je je j'ai pas voulu dire tout à fait ça
il faut évidemment que que Israël gagne
sur le Hamas comment vous voulez gagner
sur le Hamas sans faire la guerre au
Hamas il faut m'expliquer comment
comment vous gagnez une guerre sans
faire le bombardement honnêtement ça
tient pas la route on va revenir sur
cette guerre mais un dernier mot sur
cette résurgence de l'antisémitisme plus
de 1000 actes antisémites depuis le 7
octobre Bruno rotaillot le président du
groupe LR ici au Sénat dit que c'est pas
une résurgence c'est un nouvel
antisémitisme on est passé d'un anti
antisémitisme dont le terro était le
fascisme un antisémitisme dont le terro
est l'islamisme politique est-ce que
vous partagez cette analyse oui il a
raison il a raison il y a encore un
antisémitisme d'extrême droite pour pour
parler cach il y a un antisémitisme
d'une droite catholique très rétrograde
et tout vous savez un anti-judaïsme qui
a toujours existé dans dans l'Église
dans une partie de l'église bien sûr
qu'il y a ça et personne dira le
contraire je serai le dernier à à à dire
que c'est que c'est que c'est pas vrai
ça c'est une chose mais il y a
évidemment évidemment un
antisémitisme bien plus important
aujourd'hui vous savez ce qu'on appelle
l'antisémitisme des banlieux qui est des
gens qui
instrumentalisent qui connaissent
souvent rien du tout à la situation au
au au Proche Orient mais qui utiliseent
ça pour dire leur haine des leur haine
des Juifs il y a aussi un autre problème
c'est qu' a dans dans l'Islam lui-même
des des des des textes des des paroles
du prophèt qui sont évidemment qui
appellent à tuer les Juifs et tout il y
a tout ça et puis il y a une haine de la
France une haine de la France plus
généralement et s'ils ont l'occasion de
la démontrer ou de la montrer à à ce
moment-là ils le font le problème c'est
que longtemps y compris dans les médias
pardon madame moi j'étaé 40 ans
journaliste on ne parlait qu'une partie
de l'antisémitisme çait celui venir
celui qu'on connaissait de de l'extrême
droite et et et l'autre ah non non non
ces pauvres chéris dans les banlieux
pouvaient évidemment puisque ils étaient
des victimes comment tu peux être une
victime et en même temps être un salot
et oui il y a des problèmes il y a des
gens qui sont des victimes et des
antisémites les deux à la fois mais dans
la lettre d'Emmanuel Macron au français
il y a pas une seule fois le mot
islamisme est-ce qu'il aurait dû
l'employer ce mot selon vous mais c'est
c'est la lâcheté madame de la classe
politique je veux dire hier j'ai débattu
dans d'autres chaînes avec un certain
nombre de gens où c'est le mot qui
dérange vous savez moi je me suis fait
traiter pendant je sais pas combien de
temps de fachot de service parce que je
disais qu'il y avait un lien évident
évident entre une immigration pas
l'immigration une immigration non
contrôlée et et de la délinquence
aujourd'hui même le ministre le dit tout
le monde dit tout le monde a acquis ça
de la même façon je pense qu'aujourd'hui
il y a un certain nombre de gens qui
oseront dire il y a aujourd'hui le
terrorisme c'est pas du terrorisme c'est
du terrorisme islamiste auquel on a
faire on a faire face aujourd'hui
l'antisémitisme et l'antisémitisme de de
milieu touché par l'islamisme c'est
d'ailleurs un des problèmes d'hier
madame vous avez remarqué comme moi le
peu de musulmans dans ces manifestations
il y avait des berbes moi j'en ai
rencontré parce qu'ils sont venus me
saluer et tout c'est un vrai problème
pas un vrai problème pour moi un vrai
problème pour eux aujourd'hui il faut
quand il est musulman être aussi à côté
des Juifs et pas seulement euh trois
imams qui acceptent de le dire mais
massivement or hier ce n'est pas vrai à
part d'être aveugle on s'aperceveit bien
que la que la la communauté musulmane
était fort peu représentée et c'est
dommage une partie d'ailleurs parce
qu'elle a peur des islamistes eux-mêmes
qui sont capables après de les montrer
du doigt Robert Menard vous nous l'avez
dit vous vous êtes rendu en Israël il y
a quelques jours dans les kibuts
notamment comment vous vous en êtes
revenu est-ce que la situation sur place
correspond à ce qui nous parvient comme
information écoutez vous savez les les
médias comment ils fonctionnent ils
fonctionnent avec à l'aide beaucoup
d'images aujourd'hui les images qu'on a
c'est les images de ce qui se passe à
Gaza qui est terrible personne n'en dis
qu'on vient et j'ai le j'ai la crainte
et c'est ce que ce que j'ai constaté ce
qu'on m'a dit ce que m'ont dit tous mes
interlocuteurs en Israël qu'est-ce
qu'ils m'ont dit ils m'ont dit on a peur
d'être d'être oublié quand je leur
demandais qu'est-ce que je peux faire
pour vous me disais c'est pas de l'aide
dont on a besoin Israël c'est pas c'est
un pays riche donc qui a les moyens qui
aura les moyens de reconstruire
évidemment les kibuts ce qui me disent
et notre problème aujourd'hui c'est
qu'on a peur d'être oublié regardez la
petite musique aujourd'hui on renvoie
dos à dos do d'un côté ce qui s'est
passé le 7 octobre et les bombardements
attendez sauf qu'il y a une différence
de taille je suis allé à nirose à nirose
on a tué volontairement des enfants on a
tué on les les les islamistes les
terroristes du Hamas ont tuer assassiner
torturer un certain nom de gens
volontairement jusqu'à preuve du
contraire les bombes israéliennes qui
tuent qui tuent des enfants à Gaza ça ne
fait pas longombre d're et pour les
enfants c'est le même drame évidemment
la mort des uns et des autres c'est
exactement la même mais pardon les
bombes israéliennes elles ne elles ne
visent pas elles n'ont pas pour cible
les enfants israéliens et les enfants
palestiniens c'est pas la même chose
c'est dur à expliquer mais ce n'est pas
la même chose ensuite moi je comprends
totalement c'est pour ça que j'étais pas
j'étais mécontent enfin mécontent
surpris des propos cette semaine du du
chef de l'État attendez si vous voulez
éradiquer le Hamas et il le faut pour la
survie d'Israël pardon on fait pas la
paix avec des gens qui vous nient dans
ce que vous êtes on n'est pas dans un
conflit territorial où on se où on se
partage une du terrain d'un côté il y a
un état qui existe et de l'autre côté je
finis juste là-dessus de l'autre côté il
y a le Hamas qui veut qui nie non
seulement l'État mais qui ne veut pas de
juif sur tout ce qui était la Palestine
il a eu tort de réclamer un cesser le
feu Emmanuel Macron bien sûr qu'il a
tort bien sûr enfin vous faites vous
vous vous débarrassez du Hamas avec un
cess le feu mais aujourd'hui à cesser le
feu c'est permettre au Hamas de se
reconstituer des forces c'est impossible
et j'ai entendu nos amis allemands le
dire le chef de l'État allemand le dire
et il a raison aujourd'hui vous pouvez
vous pouvez demander à ce qu'il y a des
mesures humanitaires qui soient prises
vous pouvez il faut demander à ce qu'il
y a des mesures qui soient prises et
c'est vrai que d'ailleurs Israël l'a
accepté en partie puisqu'ils acceptent
maintenant un certain nombre de trêve
mais demander d'arrêter la guerre ça n'a
pas de sens aujourd'hui moi je Seris
Isra puis tout court je suis français
pas juif honnêtement se débarrasser du
Hamas c'est pour s'en débarrasser il
faut continuer la guerre et la guerre à
outrance en ce moment il y a pas d'autre
solution qu'on m'explique comment on
gagne une guerre sans bombarder les gens
je ne crois pas que ça existe Benjamin
Natania qui qui refuse tout cesser le
feu tant qu'il y aura des otages est-ce
que vous trouvez que la mobilisation
pour les otages est suffisante et
notamment pour les otages français vous
êtes maire est-ce qu'il faudrait
accrocher leur portrait au Fonton des
mairies ah mais écoutez à la mienne ils
y sont déjà je vous le dis tout de suite
et pas que les otages français
l'ensemble des otages ils sont sur la
façade de la synagogue de béziier et sur
l'hôtel de ville de Bézier bien sûr que
ce soit pas le cas dans dans dans toutes
les mairies parce que c'est le cas dans
d'autres mairies hein mais que ce soit
pas le cas dans toutes les mairies oui
mais moi j'ai parlé avec avec David
Lisnard le patron vous savez de la de
l'Association des des mares de franceche
je lui ai parlé alors que j'étais même
j'étais en Israël et j'étais dans un de
ces kibuts en lui disant écoute il faut
absolument se mobilisé de de façon plus
massive et vous savez on a le Congrès de
l'Association des mares de France oui il
m'a dit que oui non mais il est d'accord
évidemment il y a le Congrès de
l'Association des maires de France qui
va se passer dans dans quelques jours à
Paris j'espère qu'on y invitera un
certain nombre de familles de familles
d'otage d'otage à à Gaza et vous l'avez
dit il y a huit familles il y a huit
familles françaises j'espère qu'on leur
donnera la parole et que les maires de
France se mobiliseront pour ces huit
familles mais généralement pour toutes
les familles sa on va pas faire le entre
les familles d'otage qui sont françaises
et puis celles qui le sont pas
évidemment on est touché par celles qui
sont françaises mais c'est un drame pour
tout le monde évidemment merci Robert
Menard merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre
invité ce matin depuis votre mairie de
Bézier merci d'avoir été avec nous on
parle on continue à parler de ces sujets
tout de suite dans le club des
territoires